and the guy said bees
straight ahead and i looked up
and i was about to walk into a swarm of
bees
[Music]
good day and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with
me chris turner and me alice winn
hello alice winn hello chris turner um
before we
even begin let's address some things
that people
ask me to well that i feel we should
address
is the fake news thing that we did um
that oh let's address that first off
right so last week
we uh claimed uh that diane sawyer had
died in a horrific
mud car crash now i feel less
responsible for this
because i do not know who she is
honestly really know who she is either
but she's actually not
dead she is not dead as was
pointed out to us by several people on
our youtube comments who were like
dancer is not dead i can't find
everything so i kind of like the idea
that we're going to spread
misinformation about one famous person
every
except okay uh i think it was george the
first
george the first had a pretty bad
relationship with his son prince
frederick
and one of the bad things that prince
frederick did
was that one time george the first was
this of england by the way
was um thank you for all our american
listeners who famously have
um it could be you know a different
european country belgium uh
so well i mean he was from hanover
wasn't he george anyway so
um george the first was sick and prince
frederick just told everyone he was dead
and frederick was now king
and rumor reached the king george
that his son had done this and the king
was like but i'm not dead and i was like
i'm sorry he's having a party
right now whereas what he should have
done was done the charles baudelaire
thing and said i
started the rumor he should have so it
wasn't diane sawyer it was jessica
savage who was an nbc news anchor who
died in the 80s when
her and her fiance left a restaurant got
in their car in a rainstorm
drove out of the parking lot directly
into a canal
which um several people had already done
that at that restaurant and died
because the restaurant wouldn't put up a
wall it's a very sad it's a very sad
story yeah but
it wasn't diane sawyers so she's fine
she's fine she's not dead
no fake news on this podcast um that
wasn't what i was going to address but
i'm glad we addressed it
what i was going to address was several
people complained that last week
we did not show them the elk
i can only apologize i promise you if
any elk appear at the window this week i
will show you
um i have put up a sign that says
recording outside the studio so
hopefully they'll see that and know to
stay awake because it was
distracting they yeah they have little
respect for our craft
yeah but you know if any of those elk
are listening now thanks so much for
being such a big part of last week's
show they were
they were charming elk news no they know
there is elk news
like okay you talk i just don't want
this to be a segment that you're
in elk news uh alice's father came up
came up to me
a few days ago and he has a way of
delivering all news as if it's the
gravest most important
like all new it'll be like if from
telling you that there's been a terrible
world wide tragedy
that a mug has been left on the kitchen
counter when i was in primary school i
remember our form shooter mr hicks
wheeling in the television
um on 911 saying boys you need to watch
this
and we all thought oh this isn't a fun
video
you could tell yeah that's how alice's
dad approaches me he'll just go
chris i have something to tell you
and so always now i just prepare for it
to be totally fine
now whenever he approaches me with this
grave look i assume that like someone's
left their shoes in the hall
yeah um but he came to me one morning
goes chris
a mountain lion has killed an elk at the
road at the back of our house
and that's not far away an elker beer
much bigger than i am and it is concern
i go for these like lonely
like dusk time walks oh what an
evocative
image lonely dusk time walk
um she's got such a way with me i think
it's redundant to say dusk time i think
dusk is a time
um but in any case i am
that's what everyone was thinking when
they heard you say it they weren't going
what poetry they're going what a
tautological [ __ ]
it was uh yeah it's it's been depressing
because i now have to leave i have to go
for a walk with a stick
or with a you know a guardian god you'll
hate being over 75 they have to walk
with sticks all the time i will
loathe that i also want to say thank you
for everyone who's been listening so far
there's been some good feedback
we people have been given some good
constructive criticism why are you
looking that way what's happening over
there well i was just thinking because
in our first episode
we both said quite smugly that we didn't
read comments and it has become
apparent that you in fact do read well i
read comments and then filter the ones
through to alice that are complementary
to her yeah i don't want to hear any of
the comments
okay what i mean was like one of our
friends called up and said hey it was
fun to listen to you and alice she uh
she keeps you in check
and then one of your friends called you
and said oh it's really fun because
chris doesn't really know anything
[Laughter]
yeah i've been enjoying that so no thank
you very much for listening thank you
for your feedback
someone last week said get a windshield
for your mic they only cost five dollars
so i thought oh yeah why am i being so
stingy you've got a windshield for the
mic
that's that's the only reason why i
didn't get it because it was five
dollars seemed insurmountable for some
foam
uh rather than the fact that i did not
even think of that so thank you whoever
said that
i hope you're happy just before we
started recording
you you said that these podcasts will be
such comfort to you
after i'm dead yeah i i live in the
perpetual
expectation that chris will tragically
die young
i don't know why i'm just assuming it's
going to happen
and when that does inevitably it'll
probably be your dad will come up to you
with a very somber tone you'll be like
oh he's going to tell me that we've run
out of blue roll and then he'll say your
husband is
dead i really had the shoes in the hole
i mean it is just anxiety right it's
just something i do late at night as i
write your obituary in my head and it's
very very hard to get to
the way you said your obituary sounded
like your obituary
that oh my god obituaries [ __ ]
obituaries
that's genius that i think we've come
across a bit okay every week from now on
i'm gonna find a [ __ ] obituary and
read it no
we're not doing that yeah but uh
the point is that when you're tragically
killed um in the trenches i will
be able to listen to these podcasts and
think to myself
well look we can hear ourselves talking
well what i can do is i can just edit it
so it's just my microphone
and you can just have a one-sided
conversation with me and you'll be in
the middle of like pouring your heart
out i miss you so much chris and then
i'll go
oh some help that is how it goes when i
pour my heart out that is a normal
conversation
um so thank you very much for listening
thank you for providing my wife with an
outlet
to grapple with grief when i do
eventually die
um hopefully that's not a what's that
there's a quotation isn't it it's the
oldest story in the world
someone goes first that's really sad
yeah oh i don't like that it's terrible
isn't it baby shoes for sale
never worn you know for sale baby shoes
never worn okay
butcher hemingway's words what i was
doing was
quoting it from the idols album because
he says it that way around i just
pronounced album as an album
maybe i've got it wrong anyway never
mind and she doesn't read the news you
know what happens this one doesn't read
the news so i tell her what's going on
that week
main story this week down here in texas
where all the cowboys are it's snowing
don't do it with that glee because
people are dying no okay yes i know
about this because
as we all know uh once in a while out of
a sort of act of
masochism and self-harm i go on buzzfeed
and
uh i did that last week and lots and
lots of pictures of like
swimming pools frozen over um and
like ice coming out of taps
not as many pictures of people who've
died because they've gone into their
garage
got into their car to keep warm and died
from carbon monoxide it's quite grim
isn't it and everyone's having to pay
more money for their ridiculous bills
like their bills have gone up despite
the fact that they're not actually
getting any power
so they are using power but there was
some
rule that was passed by the texas
council or whatever
the correct word is saying um
oh yeah it's supply and demand so the
energy company can charge
as much as they want and so people who
for per megawatt hour or kilowatt
kilowatt hour not megawatt
per kilowatt hour which is a measurement
of electricity used to pay 50
and now it's gone up to ten thousand
dollars so there are people who have
17 000 electricity bills and when they
complained to the company the company
said
yeah we understand it's a really kind of
difficult time it will like make an
exception so we'll
set up a payment plan for you to pay
this off and that's for like three days
of electricity
when people are having to boil water
to drink it because it's unsafe i mean
let's let's break down what happened
um texas is the only state in america
that has an independent
power grid so why does it have that is
it is it to do with secession
is it because texas wants to be its own
country texas was briefly its own
country
um yeah i mean i think i think a lot of
um more conservative states are very
concerned with states rights so maybe
it's to do with that
what i would imagine is texas is
actually one of the biggest producers of
energy in the u.s so wind power natural
gas and
coal and oil no maybe not coal but oil
it's also
enormous oh it's a big old place it is
five
times the size of france wow
so i can i can kind of understand why i
might be like look we're just going to
sort this out ourselves because it's
easier
yeah so and they have their own um
not-for-profit electricity
company which is then weird that it's
not not for profit when you know they
are making such amounts of money kind of
it feels exploitative
but what happened was the
infrastructure's not there
power stations went offline because
because they're not used to ice and snow
yeah they're not used these temperatures
so the gas mains
froze like right they couldn't get the
gas through because the mains froze the
water pipes
burst pylons everything were brought
down
it meant people were without electricity
for you know three four days i think
this was like five million people had no
power
and if you've got no power you've got no
heating i mean that's got no water and
it's not
and those buildings are going to have
been built they're not insulated in any
way
they're built to withstand heat right i
mean one of the coldest
times of my life is when i was in um
venice italy in march
because those those sort of palazzos are
built
for sorry that sounds so wanky but
anyway
the pilates i was taking the pilates
let's just say
right like venetian palazzos are often
like french chateaus they are not
they're dilapidated yeah they're
run down they're in ruin now obviously
alice was staying in a very fancy
palazzo because she
all that no it wasn't that it was just
it was just nice but it did not have
really heating or anything and it was
just
it wasn't even that cold but it was damp
and
you know you're in this like big marble
like
summer palace and it just it was so cold
it was so cold and so texas all those
buildings are built like that they're
built
to be out of marble yeah yeah and
and to impress impress the pope when
um no but so i can't even imagine i mean
it must be awful
so it feels like what's terrible about
this is that
you have sort of three things conspiring
at once one is climate change
like having some wack weather there and
you know
that republican politicians aren't going
to do what they should do after this
which is go oh
we need to give money to prepare for
this because this is going to happen
regularly
they're going to say where's all this
global warming we've been hearing of
this is more like
you should burn more oil climate change
climate change whenever people say do a
wrap up global warming
one i say i've been asked to do that
about 12 times but two i say oh you just
climate change is that right
because my geography teacher used to
tell us off if ever we said global
warming he'd go
climate change it's misleading um so
there's that and then the second thing
is
that the power couldn't handle it and
then the third thing is that this this
bizarre thing of the power companies
being able to charge this much money i
mean it doesn't
make any sense it's kafka-esque so the
power companies are
making profit out of people's misfortune
what's new
capitalism wait hang on though let's
let's think about this for a second um
let's assume for a moment that the power
companies are not run
by just monstrous capitalist demons
they must have an arg they're not
sitting there cackling going i can't
wait until the people die and have to
pay us money
what's their reasoning for this well if
they are a not-for-profit corporation
then that's just their running costs to
get these
electricities and yeah that's that's how
it works
but i just feel like that's very unfair
like it seems like it's not the person's
fault that wants the electricity they're
like i'm trying to keep alive by putting
this heat on and the power company is
going yeah okay
but he pays this much money no i mean it
does it seems it's like the american
healthcare system
you know like oh we can remove that mold
for you because it looks cancerous
this is what happened to me so i went to
the doctor and i showed them a mull
and i was like does this have a count
this is a cancer mole and they were like
yeah it looks pretty cancerous
it'll be 400 to remove it would you like
us to remove it and i was like
uh you think it's cancerous and they're
like oh yeah yeah
four hundred dollars and i was like
that's really expensive and they're like
well we can leave it if you want
but it is probably cancer what you
should have done is get it in writing
that if it wasn't cancer you get the
refurbishment
no cancer all your money um but anyway
it wasn't even cancer in the end so
there you go
i guess what i'm trying to get at is
whenever someone is doing something like
this that seems so
abjectly evil i'm always curious about
how they're justifying it to themselves
because
very few people are just okay
with being abjectly evil there must be
some kind of
reasoning that they have followed to
arrive at this conclusion which to them
justifies this moral decision i just
can't i can't imagine what it is
yeah i can't see how you don't just go
oh well they've been given a 10 000
power bill for using the same amount
they would use every month
let's not charge them for that that's
what i would think
that seems like the sensible thing no i
mean i completely agree i just i j they
j
yeah i don't understand it i would like
to i'd be curious to talk to someone who
who was on the if you work for the texan
power
authority then comment below and tell us
why you are charging these people so
much money
but that wasn't the biggest news story
coming out of texas this week big one
was
the big old teddy cruz went on holiday
he went off he thought well my state's
in trouble tell you what let's go dip my
toes in the ocean so here's a question
did he i mean presumably he had booked
these flights to cancun before so it was
more that he
don't know although someone from united
did leak his flight details in the
united are now saying
we're going to look into this because
it's a violation of privacy which i mean
it is but they leaked it to show that he
had said oh i was just going to fly
down and drop my daughters off then come
back and various people pointed out
oh it looks like your suitcase was
packed for a week and also
someone from united said oh no his
flight was scheduled for the weekend
so let me just uh clarify it so um
obviously
when your state is having a you know a
miserable um
thing like this you should it's not good
leadership to leave right think about
queen elizabeth
um and her family they didn't you know
hide during world war ii they stayed in
britain to you know muster the troops um
but is the general like let's say he had
booked it a while ago is the general
idea that it's just
because you shouldn't be on holiday
during pandemic i think any leaders when
the place you lead is in crisis you
should be there
even if it's not necessarily you know to
do things although today they
photographed him
handing out pallets of water at like a
best buy
to help people which is you know pr mop
up
because i mean it's damaged him hugely
like how can it not
also he left his poodle at home his
poodle's called snowflake which is
good banter ted cruz that's pretty good
quite lols yeah yeah
um so yeah he he he came back
immediately the next day
because of this outcry my favorite thing
was when it broke i was on twitter and i
saw someone post the picture
really early on of him at the airport
and it was just people arguing going
that's not him
no it is him and then people started
sleuthing and they put up pictures and
they're like he wears these sneakers
look that is him someone goes he's
wearing the same face mask
but his hair looks different how it did
earlier this week because earlier in the
week someone had photographed him he'd
had done like an undercut at the side of
his hair
like yeah 50 year old dad with an
undercut nothing says midlife crisis
like undercut and flying to cancun yeah
he's um
he's he's taking it in the neck for that
yeah i
i um i think it probably made it look
worse that he didn't just kind of fess
up and go like look i'd
booked a holiday and then i you know
came back when i realized
yeah i mean the fair thing is to say hey
look i've got
a [ __ ] ton of money my state was cold i
went somewhere warm baby
and i think a lot of republicans would
be like yeah that's what i'd do and if i
pull myself up with my bootstraps i can
do that uh yeah
that is true they are good about that
they're good about being like listen
when i'm a billionaire
i want to not have to pay tax another
great thing to come out of it was
the the family whatsapp thread
or some text messages sent by ted cruz's
wife to her neighbors saying
hey y'all we're going to cancun it's
only 300 rooms at the hotel who wants to
join us and then
several people on that thread
individually leaked them to the press
and you go oh wow these friends don't
like you
uh okay here's where i have to um say
out loud that i don't
completely know who ted cruz is he is
the son of the zodiac killer
he's not according to donald trump
during the republican primaries donald
trump just kept going
well ted cruz he's pretty weird and his
dad's the zodiac killer
that's so you can't just go i mean maybe
you can just go around saying [ __ ] like
that that's great
you cannot slander the dead i don't
think i think
i think that um in america slandering
libel laws
the proof for you have to prove the
person being
like spoken about falsely has to prove
that it's not true
because the zodiac killer was never
caught it could be any one of us
right god that's that's so sneaky okay
but you still haven't explained exactly
is he a politician
he's a politician he is he's the senator
for texas
so that's quite an important job really
yeah yeah and has he ever run for
president
uh he won he ran in the republican
primary last cycle but donald trump won
not him right and many people think he
wants to run in 2024
but many people also say that this has
absolutely buggered him on that front
that's a good thing then well yeah
except it's a good thing except for the
fact that um whenever we think
someone is truly awful and thank god
they're not going to be able to be
king of america someone even worse shows
up
yeah i mean take all this with a grain
of salt right this could all not have
happened just like diane sawyer is not
dead
because i only got this news from your
mother who told me hey see what happened
to ted cruz
so that oh look some elk there's not
really any elk stop complaining
one thing to come out of the whole ted
cruz scandal as well is
uh right-wing media have been pointing
out how much air time has been paid
attention to ted cruz on the left and
central news outlets
but less attention paid to andrew cuomo
so lest we get
any of you know people they're going
you're not talking about andrew crowley
he's from new york
andrew cuomo is he is new york that's
his catchphrase he sits down he goes i'm
andrew cuomo i'm new york baby
the scandal with cuomo is it turns out
that during the kind of height of the
pandemic
when they were reporting deaths he held
back from reporting deaths of elderly
people in care homes
which i think he said it was fine for
people to stay there
and send people back to care homes from
hospital even though other people said
they were dangerous
they didn't report the figures and
under-reported them in some cases by
about 50
because they were worried about taking
you know hits from
trump from the media and that's
obviously a
[ __ ] thing to do that's like a huge
cover-up you don't you can't do that
he's denied this he said this is all
lies
um but the evidence seems to suggest
something
different so we mention it because i
don't want to
you know have people say oh what about
cuomo thing is
it's not as funny as a man going on
holiday to cancun is it
and this is first and foremost a
comedically minded podcast yeah it's not
not that funny um oh people dying comedy
gold more pandemic stuff
the uh numbers are out of life
expectancy
and life expectancy in the us fell by
more than a year
during the first half the pandemic i'm
not very good at maths that doesn't seem
like that much
it's just we've never had a drop like
that it's been a long time since we've
had
when was the last drop like that last
time we had a drop like this world war
ii
i was thinking it would be world war ii
yeah um and it's it's really bad so the
life expectancy for the entire
population dropped to 77.8 years
um greater changes amongst ethnic
minority groups black men
life expenses dropped by three years
hispanic men two and a half
hispanic women 1.1 so life expectancy at
birth of american men is now 75 years
and for women 80 years so you're gonna
have five years where you're going to
listen to our podcasts to keep you going
we were talking about this this morning
uh because you said that we're up to
around half a minute half a million
dollars death in america from pandemic
and i think america
lost a little a little under five
five hundred thousand uh men in world
war two okay
i think um and so yeah we're we're
it's only been yes a year and world war
ii was yeah they were involved for like
four years i mean this is it's the
country with the most deaths reported
obviously some countries may not have
reported
right for example north korea no deaths
from covert
it's incredibly amazing well done kind
of weird
how it came out this week that north
korea have been hacking pfizer to try
and get the vaccine
why are you trying to get the vaccine
when you haven't got covered in you
they're just they're just taking
precautions why are you getting two
million doses of the oxford vaccine sent
to you
when uh well chris listen i admire the
ingenuity and making sure that they ward
off
the disease given that they don't have
it in their country that's very true
yeah get everyone vaccinated i mean
we've reached the point in la county
where
predicted that 55 of people up to 55
people may have had covered wow and so
they're getting close to herd immunity
at that point it depends yes no one
is heard immunity 50 is it 90 percent i
thought it was 70 well that's it that's
kind of
right in the middle right but um yeah
rates are dropping really fast in la
because so many people have already had
it wow
that's not a good thing because so many
people died
yeah no i mean it is really terrible
so much death so much destruction but
let's talk about some fun stuff
something a bit nicer now something a
bit lighter a little bit lovelier
um do you know what the perseverance
rover is
it's on mars and it tweeted yes it did
well done i thought you're going to go
oh isn't he an irish folk hero
or the persimmon rover oh he rosie here
he rosie there
i can't really do an irish accent though
no neither of us can yeah uh you could
speak a bit of irish do a bit of irish
diegoch
you sound like a small korean girl what
was it what was that you're saying um
hello um how are you my name is alice
well that's good
um i speak no irish but um yeah that's
good well done well done that's really
all i can remember i went to gaelic camp
when i was 17.
we should clarify gaelic is the language
spoken in ireland it is not a variation
of bredlich poetry focused with penises
but the thing about gaelic as a term is
that in ireland they don't really call
it gay like i only call it gaelic camp
because otherwise people think
if you say you went to irish camp that
sounds like a camp to hang out with
irish people
whereas it was a wait wait are you
saying it wasn't it was but
as in it was so strict like you you
couldn't have you had to turn in your
phone
your ipod you couldn't have any books
you weren't allowed to write in english
you weren't allowed to read in english
they dubbed over lady gaga songs
with irish lyrics so that we could sing
along what is bad romance in irish i
can't i used to know
ring ring ring ring is that how
telephone goes
i don't think that's i was reading a
retrospective review of katy perry's
teenage dream
album this morning and it did remind me
he said
this album contains one of the worst
lyrics in pop music which is do you ever
feel like a plastic bag
from firework and it points out that bad
lyrics don't hinder you because she sang
that song for the president
so well done katy perry he did also
point out that was the uh
the first album since bad by michael
jackson to have five number one songs
from no it's an incredible album
i don't really like music but um she's
had so many snapchats it's incredible
yeah irish camp yeah uh gaelic camp
didn't you get lost when you were there
okay so there was a whole
thing basically what happened was um my
mother had signed me up to irish
camp with um
like her family name it was an irish
name
and so when i got on the bus everyone
was only speaking irish and i could not
speak a word of irish and they took
roll call uh they read out my name
in irish so it was like alice knee
you know and then this other name that
not only is it not actually my name
it's my mother's name but it's also it
was in an irish
well also names in other languages are
impenetrable so i watched the raid which
is an
indonesian martial arts film and
they keep using each other's names when
you listen to them speaking you don't
hear that name in it
because it sounds really different and
it's not like oh no they translate in
the name even in french like they'll say
stuff and
like speak to me and say my name yeah
but say a sentence like kind of i've got
a coffee order here for chris
um okay i can't tell that french is a
bad example but
it's the language he could speak the
point is the point is
that i didn't answer uh when they called
my name and
so the camp called up my parents and
were like um all right your daughter
hasn't arrived
but i had texted my parents when i got
in the taxi from the airport saying i'm
in the taxi
so my parents were like she got in the
taxi and has not arrived
so they consulted the american
embassy and the american embassy was
like
this is there's been a spate of taxi
murders they said that like two days
before
a taxi driver had picked someone up from
the airport and murdered them
and everyone in ireland started freaking
out because everyone in ireland
seriously no here it was like it was a
foreign policy thing because no one
wants like a
17 year old american girl to be murdered
at the irish airport like that's not
good
i mean one one is careless but two
so so my parents were getting these
phone calls from like the
head of irish you know police
departments and stuff and it was just
like turning into this massive panic
and i was safe and sound at my irish
camp making new irish friends
and finally there was you going oh have
you heard the news
there's a girl being murdered at the
airport in a taxi like oh that's so
terrible an american girl or apparently
looks just like you no because i
couldn't understand a word anyone was
saying we were operating entirely
through charades
i um finally finally they figured out
where i was
and um yeah so that was it i hadn't been
murdered that's the story
so glad otherwise i'd have to listen to
these podcasts over and over again
before we'd even recorded them it
would've been so difficult
uh two things once i was at an airport i
was in mumbai
for some shows and i was waiting in the
queue for customs
and they'd said that they'd arranged a
taxi to pick me up i went in the queue
for customs
and i saw these two men approaching me
like walking towards me like customs
guards and i thought
oh this isn't good that's never good
and there was a big sign when you came
into the airport that listed the things
you should not bring
into india and number one was you know
food
two like foreign food number two was
drugs number three was pornographic
content
and i started thinking huh well how do
they
because like porn's not physical now
like what if what if there's like stuff
on someone's laptop or someone's phone
oh well how would they look up for that
and so when these two guys approached me
i started thinking
oh no oh someone's tipped them off
um and then they just walked me through
customs without even checking and then
the other side just stood there looking
at me
and i i was like oh thank you so what i
thought was going to be arrested was
actually
white privilege because it turned out i
got sped through and i told this someone
they said well did you give them money
and i said no
and they said well they were expecting
you to give them money and it turned out
during that whole trip in mumbai
so many times i was oblivious to someone
doing something nice to me and i thought
well yes i'm chris turner
and it turned out that i was supposed to
give the money one time i was waiting
for a taxi
and this guy kept going no it's going to
be there it's gonna be there i mean like
it should be five minutes it should be
five minutes and what i realized was oh
it'll be five minutes if i give him
money
and so it took an hour until i realized
oh i have to give him money
i i used to drive my ex-boyfriend insane
because you know how in places like
paris there's a always there's like
there's rose
salesmen you know they're like wander
around holding up they hold out a rose
to you
and then the idea is the ball you're
with is supposed to buy you the rose but
every time this happened
i just thought that someone was giving
me the rose for free because i was so
pretty
and my ex-boyfriend would just be like
alice don't take the rose because i
don't want to have to keep buying you
all these flowers and i would be like no
he's giving them to me for free and they
never were
um it was very annoying we lived these
charmed lives the other thing
uh related to school trips and people
misunderstanding stuff was
at my school there was a thing called
desert trek and you know this story
but desert trek every year took a group
of boys
to go to a desert and trek it which is
for like 13 year olds a big thing like
hey guys kalahari time oh let's go be it
up
and i if you were hoping to have any
street cred for your like traumatic
childhood i think you just lost it
[Laughter]
i've never claimed to be anything i'm
not i
um started from the middle and i'm here
[Laughter]
so one of my my form tutors not the one
who wheeled in the television on
september 11th but uh our french
tutor madame boylan was one of the
supervising adults
on this desert trip and entering
maybe four or five days into the trip
they were they were trekking across the
sahara or wherever it is and i didn't
say sahara desert because i'm not a
tortological [ __ ] like this one here
because sahara means desert guys five
days into the trek
one of the students faints while on the
desert track
and the school have to alert parents
when that happens they have to say hey
your kid's sick but it's fine
so madame boylan who obviously spoke
english but was a fluent
you know native french speaker called up
the parents and left a voicemail because
they weren't available
saying hello i just have to tell you
that
james has passed on but uh we are taking
care of everything it will be fine so do
not worry you can call back if you get
this
but uh you're in the desert so maybe no
signal okay bye-bye
what madam boyle i meant to say was
james has passed out
but so can you imagine the horror and
terror of these parents who were unable
to reach the group for
some time of the day because it was in a
desert
just going well our child is dead but
apparently we shouldn't worry says this
jovial french woman
it's all being taken care of you know
what this reminds me of of course
world war one oh my god because robert
graves
was mistakenly um reported dead
and uh yeah he rocked but he like
knocked he went back home
and everyone was like we already had
your funeral like you're dead
and he's like not me i'm fine back to
the red planet
so the mars rover tweeted something i
thought quite inane really just shows
that
by that i don't think it tweeted i think
it sent a photo back and then someone at
nasa tweeted i don't think you waste
valuable processing power on a space
module to you know log into twitter
no i prefer to think of it it tweak
tweeting it uses little robot fingers
and it's robot phone through the cell
towers and it's also wasting its life
right it's supposed to be doing
something on mars but instead it's
procrastinating
it's kind of looking through kelly
oxford's tweet tweets
who's kelly oxford she's like a tweet
tweeter she tweets things okay cool
never never heard of her
you know she's probably dead she's
probably died in a car accident he's not
dead
either in a car accident or abducted an
airport in a taxi
so mars rover it's looking for life
it's a big deal it's the first photos in
color we're going to get
back from mars which is cool because
from the surface of mars um
it's cool because it's red in it we can
find that out good on the mars rover
like let's hope it find let's hope it
doesn't find life that'd be absolutely
terrible you don't want any life to be
found
not proper aliens like you can find like
an organism although that's probably
going to come back with it and kill us
all
i just think pandemic 2020 generally
speaking i'd rather not know if there's
any
aliens around because i don't think it's
going to end well why do you hate david
bowie isn't it
is that life shut up david stop it stop
it
uh some music news in spain there was a
rapper called
the rain in spain falls mainly on the
plane that's his most famous song
yeah of the bringing the spring falls
mainly on the planet
he's a spanish rapper called pablo
hassell uh
yes i said that correct uh and he's he's
in jail
and his fans and pretty much everyone in
spain ain't happy about that
so at the start of the week he
barricaded himself into university
because they had sentenced him to nine
months in jail for
um lyrics glorifying terrorism and
anti-monarchist sentiments so well you
can't put someone in jail because of
anti-monaco center well in spain you can
and they
they've been putting people in jail um
for
one of them someone tweeted a couple of
years ago about an
assassination of um franco's
like right-hand man
decades ago and got put in jail for it
they're they're saying you cannot and
this so this is in catalonia which is
catholic the catalans it's barcelona
football club right
believe they are a separate part of
spain it's a separate kingdom right do
you know the historical stuff
well yeah i mean lots of spain the
maybe i'm out of date the unification of
spain happened with ferdinand and
isabella in the
1400s okay but before then they were
kind of different kingdoms and they had
you know
up until that point pretty different um
paths because
uh of the way the patterns of moorish
invasion
and i think by that you mean invasions
by the moors not
moorish invasion like all these cream
bombs yeah go on
uh yeah invasions by the moors i'm i'm
talking uh
in the margins of my knowledge now i
don't really know much about um
about spain's history but i do know they
yeah so there's like you know the basque
region
so um atletico bilbao or a basque
football club and only sign
basque players and that's basque names
you have loads of exes
in um i just do a joke about that like
you know a girl likes when you get more
exes on the text than the lineup of a
basque football team
no one ever laughed at that chat um i do
know about spain that the spanish
inquisition
can you guess when it ended
[Music]
i cannot nor can i come up with a funny
answer okay so it seems like a very
medieval thing yes
right um so isabel and ferdinand started
in the 1400s
uh you know etc killing um
non-christians it didn't technically end
until the 1800s when napoleon invaded
that's a 400 year i think everyone
listening was just like we don't
understand any of these dates nor any of
these times like is that early is that
like
really late okay that's so late yeah the
last woman
in england hanged for witchcraft was
probably in 1960 or something it wasn't
but the last person guillotined in
france was the 1970s i think it was the
same year as star wars came out
wow that's pretty awful isn't it you
would have thought they at least
lightsabered them to death
a a pablo hassle rapper said some bad
things about the king which
is total [ __ ] like it's great that
in the uk we can say
[ __ ] the queen and there's nothing wrong
with that but we shouldn't say that we
shouldn't say that she's dead
i'm patriotic she's so lovely and also
prince philip's in hospital
worldwide yes um who knows he's 100 i
was hoping we'd get some breaking news
today that i could put in about that but
no he's not he's uh i can't
wish for phillips well you can hear not
in spain though if you're in spain do
not do that uh
so so spain has a queen i think
and so you're not allowed to say
anything bad about the queen i guess not
so he was taken
out of the university and there have
been riots for five straight days
in in spain presumably in barcelona
um well because it's really messed up
isn't it yeah no they've lost their
freedom of speech like
it's crazy it's really bad like bloggers
vloggers
tweeters rappers and you think rap you
should be able to say whatever you want
i agree because obviously lots of time
you know what if he says like
i've got a big fat god i want to pop the
thing want to walk to the palace and
shot the king that's not his fault it
rhymed he had to say it
maybe he doesn't even believe it i mean
he definitely does believe what he's
saying okay so
i guess really the question is
pro-terror
terrorist sentiment is a little bit but
then what they say is terrorists
is what they classify as freedom
fighters now i do accept that that's
what all terrorist class themselves does
however like in in catalonia
they in catalonia they wanted a
referendum
they like had a vote saying let's have a
referendum on catalan independence
and the people who organized the vote on
catalan independence were put in jail
as terrorists that's a bit weird isn't
it so for them pro-terrorist sentiment
is saying let's have a separate
catalonia
spain's always doing dodgy stuff i feel
like yeah the spanish
i mean they've got they've got some you
know lovely paintings
but let me tell you they've got a lovely
queen and if you listen queen please
don't throw me in jail
can we be thrown in jail for something
we say about spain
no we're in america we have freedom of
speech we have freedom and expensive
electricity
fun little news story police officers in
cincinnati intercepted a shipment of
cornflakes headed from south america to
a private residence in hong kong
can you guess why they intercepted these
corn flakes
were there drugs in them they were drugs
they were cocaine-frosted cornflakes
almost three million dollars worth of
cocaine frosted on cornflakes
and they said they were like oh why is
someone shipping cornflake because
that's the thing you might think ah this
is very clever
why would you ship it too clever isn't
it from south america to hong kong
like when i was growing up and was on
holiday in menorca which is a spanish
island
i used to love the donuts there these
packs of six glazed donuts that were so
beautiful and i said
when i'm rich i'm either going to hire
the chef from the factory to come to my
house and make them every day
or i would just ship them because they
still taste good or not [ __ ]
fly them because they still taste good
about a day later to my house
i can understand that right so i might
want to ship donuts from spain
to colorado cocaine-covered so if you do
want to ship cocaine from spain let me
know because i've got the backstory
but yeah apparently they inset the
cornflakes and went oh
these look a little bit cocaine-y for
the frosted flakes
apparently the powder on them was gray
because the way they'd done it and made
it grey so that's the giveaway
it sounds like it'll be difficult to
extricate the cocaine from the
cornflakes yeah
yeah or maybe the guy who was getting
them was just going to sell the course
like it's just raw and just give them
out like hey it's like
some milk with a spoon they're great
sad pop culture news what marriage is
coming to an end
kim and kanye why are you reading the
[ __ ] news what's going on here
babe babe babe i
i'm on instagram i know anything that
comes by instagram okay
so i will tell you what i've read about
kim and kanye right because
uh the word on the street okay is that
resident
genius chris you're trying to make
yourself sound much cooler than you are
i went to gaelic camp put the word on
the street
i'm actually hard as nails okay so kris
jenner as we all know
is basically the modern version of
empress maria theresa
she is a sorry who is that
empress maria teresa yeah you're saying
that as if
everyone listening doesn't know who that
is is an idiot
she's you are outnumbered here nobody
someone listening has gone oh yeah i
think i own some lingerie by her no one
knows who that is
empress maria teresa is so cool so she's
the reason that we fought the war of
austrian succession oh with the battle
of jenkins earlier i think that was in
there yeah so basically
um yeah she inherited the throne and it
was a big old battle owning war because
everyone was like you can't have the
throne you're a woman and then she won
the throne and
whatever point is she had like 14
children and she
um played them like chess uh very like
chris jenner so seven of her children
were white seven of her children were
black
she um she basically i mean she we're
talking about you know it's the 1700s um
foreign policy through marriage so uh
you know she's the reason that mary
antoinette married
uh louis the 16th in fact
mary antoinette wasn't supposed to marry
luke the 16th um that was supposed to be
carolina but then there was this
elaborate story which i'm gonna tell you
this is why your friend got in touch and
said it's so interesting because chris
doesn't know anything at all
what you mean is you and them are
massive nerds who know these
stupid niche things yes shout out to uh
to my friend who is a history too is he
gonna be upset that i called his subject
a stupid niche thing
we must study history unless we are
doomed to repeat it
now may study cocaine cornflakes he
studies the american constitution i
think which is quite relevant
lauren boba did a very good tweet this
week saying defending the constitution
doesn't mean rewriting the parts you
don't like and then everyone's replying
like
hey we've had 27 constitutional
amendments so uh it pretty much
does mean our local representative i
think
is she no she can't be her her
banners and posters were up prior to the
election all right let me tell you more
about uh maria theresa so the point is
um backstory on mary antoinette i think
this is really relevant to kim and kanye
so strap
in so um basically um her most beautiful
daughter
maria theresa's most beautiful dog sorry
is that a cat it's a very loud cat
let's let him in sorry it's not an elk
but we can show you
a cat bring bring that fine feline over
here oh he's just right at the door he's
so indignant
he is right show him off for those of
you who don't know and if you don't know
then
come on guys this is colonel
widdershin's he's
a big cat he's he's actually shaved like
ted cruz's haircut at the moment because
he had a few mats in him so we had to
undercut him he is uh
a very good boy but he's also very upset
that he wasn't allowed in here while we
were recording
and we've now lost alice yeah no i'm
back empress maria theresa's most
beautiful daughter was called elizabeth
so um empress maria theresa's son
had married this woman called josefina
who no one liked josefina
that sounds like a rap put down for
someone in like the new meganistalian
song
it's a real name should have seen it i
think it's just enough
it's like a hispanic it's like a common
hispanic name okay cool because
because they say jesus rather than jesus
yeah um so he married this woman called
hosafina who no one liked and then she
died of smallpox
and no one liked us so no one wanted to
go to the funeral so
empress maria teresa was terrifying and
she was like elizabeth you must go to
the funeral to show that the family is
supportive
so elizabeth went to the funeral and
contracted smallpox from the grave
whoa and so then how is she doing that
because the smallpox is really
contagious
um so then her beauty was utterly marred
by the scars on her face and she was
shut shunted into a convent and so all
that well they did it with others in the
past yeah basically
get me to a nunnery oh because you want
no because you're ugly
um and so she was sent into a content
all the girls got like
moved up a slot so uh carolina who was
much more intelligent than mary
antoinette was supposed to go and marry
louis xvi but instead she went and
married the king of naples and marry
antoinette married louis xvi
and if carolina had been queen of france
really everything might have been quite
different because she was um she was a
much more with it sort of person
anyway the reason this is related to kim
and kanye kris jenner is married
chris yes kris jenner is a sort of
evil genius and i was reading this thing
or
watching a thing on tik tok about um how
it was a lawyer right who was like
in california the date of separation
is really really important in a divorce
settlement because the date that you
guys separated
that day from then on you are no longer
responsible
for each other's debts or earnings and
so basically
kim apparently wasn't ready to separate
yet
but kanye has a bunch of dates that were
a bunch of debts that we're about to
come in
to play and so kris jenner we think
deliberately leaked that they had
separated so that they could then prove
in court
that that kim kardashian was not
responsible for kanye west's debts
what a crafty crush she's an empress
that's
all the week's news and as always it is
all the week's news the definitive
every bit of news breaking news i have a
cat on my lap it's such a good cat
and uh other breaking news so this
relates to a news story that happened
earlier this week where
bill gates said um every rich nation
should be moving to synthetic beef
it says like we have once we have the
full technology there should be no
reason why rich nations
are eating uh beef from cattle
they should be doing this and that'll
help the planet and you know some people
are like shut up you're trying to
put a chip in my arm i i have to say
while i i understand where he's coming
from
i doesn't synthetic beef seem like the
kind of thing
okay so in in la um
loads of people are vegans so they all
started drinking almond milk instead of
real milk and then it turns out that
actually almonds
contribute to like just the
they just devastate california farmland
land and basically when you when you
kind of
mass create food like that's the real
problem um i know he's such a darling
can you stop showing off these uh i'm
just showing off how strong i am how
tolerant he is
i guess i guess i just i worry that if
you start mass producing synthetic beef
there's gonna be
some hideous unforeseen consequences
possible yeah i should just clarify for
our listeners rather than our viewers uh
when alice said stop showing off i was
bicep curling the cat yes he's a big fat
fluffy cat he weighs about uh 11 pounds
he's much handsomer than either pretty
strong
this gives me a chance to bring out my
favorite vegan fact which
is um avocados technically aren't vegan
because they are
produced by bees every year to pollinate
avocado orchards
beekeepers apiarists are paid to
rent out their hives and the hives are
put on trucks driven round california
from avocado orchard avocado orchard
and sorry the bees are put on trucks
yeah like a big truck full of bees can
you imagine a worse nightmare
imagine if you crashed into a truck of
bees that would be pretty bad so they
drive the beehives round
and then the bees pulling it and they're
drunk okay i'm sorry i was imagining
that literally
i was imagining not hyped i was
imagining just that you open the door
and just
uh fill it with something it's just full
of just a swarm of bees
that's great alice has a good swarm of
bees story
okay i was walking to work and i had my
headphones in
and this guy was trying to talk to me
and i was just like
ugh the patriarchy can't these people
leave me alone
can't wait till i'm not beautiful
anymore and i can finally be left alone
in peace
so i took off my headphone and the guy
said
bees straight ahead
and i looked up and i was about to walk
into a swarm of bees
and i was like thanks but he'd already
gone and then as he walked away he went
nice ass
i just i was just like you know what
that is one of the few times when a man
absolutely had the right to shout at me
on the street it was to tell me about
the swarm of peace
it's not cat calling it's be warning
exactly
beware hey you should have said that
um so the the breaking news is that the
mayor of
lyon which is in france so get ready to
do some french accents
of leon has been in trouble with the
french
government because he is from the green
party he's a green mare
and he has said that uh french schools
should not be serving meat on their menu
so he has changed
he has changed the school menu
especially because leone's cuisine is
mainly based around meat and awful
um and so he said look this is a thing
we are doing during the
coronavirus pandemic because there is a
shortage of the supply chain
and people are very mad yeah well the
french
predominant so i grew up in in paris and
uh i was a vegetarian i decided i was
vegetarian at the age of six
and i remember that my school took us on
this school trip and we were like we
slept away for
like a week and and they called your
parents and said we have lost ellie she
doesn't know her name
but um they were like i told them i was
a vegetarian
and they asked me where my papers were
so uh yeah i can see that that wouldn't
go over well the french feel pretty
pretty um
possessive of their meat so the
government the agricultural minister
hit back saying that um gregory ducey
who was the mayor
was risking children's health and he
said
let's stop putting ideology on our
children's plates
um i love that line eh but b that
reminds me of another thing which is
that uh i remember when i was 13 and i
went to a doctor in france
um and i told them i was a vegetarian
and the doctor very seriously told me
that if i did not start eating meat
again i would be blind by the time i was
21. wow
sorry there's a slight change in the
light where you're moving
i'm not sure for our listeners what i
did there was bicep curl the cat in
front of alice's face so
yeah i mean this is this mayor has
history he has previous because he's
previously uh derided the tour de france
the french cycling race
he sounds like a an unfrench uh you know
on
anti-patriots i pronounce his name is
gregory dusay i should have been like
greg duckett
because he sounds like he's proper not
uh but he said that the tour de france
is a polluting and macho
i i mean i i feel mixed between quite
liking him and also
uh thinking he sounds like a dirty
traitor to the french quarters yeah
that's that's the last guillotine he
shouldn't be in 1970
should be in 2021 for greg duckett uh
chris if you say things like that i
think you're going to find that the
spanish government are going to beat you
very good that's the breaking news which
means that's the end of all the week's
news
um well done for sticking it out and
would you feel like you've learned
something do you feel like you've become
a more well-rounded individual
i think it's interesting realizing that
i um i have actually picked up on most
of the news
i think i um people tell you the news
when you catch up with them
yeah it's weird it's like when people
say you know oh so you know tell me
about yourself and they tell you their
job
and in the past that didn't used to be a
thing right it wasn't your job that
defines you whereas now it feels like
that increasingly does
um in france in france you don't talk
about your jobs your mum was telling me
so again
could be a lie but she said like in
france you never you can know people for
15 years and not really know what they
do
i think america has um because so much
of american culture like the american
dream
is you can do anything you want and you
can be anyone who you want to be as long
as you just you know buy into the
capitalist system and and
work hard et cetera i think therefore
your career is so closely linked to your
identity and i don't think that's always
the case
in other countries but you you've got a
well-rounded grasp of the week now
well yeah i just i just um i think
people bring up the news and so i end up
actually catching fragments of it um but
it's sort of nice to fill in things
speaking about catching fragments i
didn't talk about this but um a plane
in denver boeing 777. i did hear about
this so what are you look i'm sorry guys
that this whole format and concept has
just been undermined at every turn by
this
wench who persists in reading i don't
read the news i don't i hear the news
i'm i
i it's like the you're the equivalent of
the title of the podcast still
counts um yes so this plane the engine
stopped and then it well the engine
housing just blew up and then
caught on fire so they landed safely
everyone was fine but
bits of plane fell over denver so people
were describing how they
saw things falling from the sky and they
described it as floating because it's
huge bits of metal but obviously it's
very light
obviously it's still heavy but it's
light for its size so
casings of engines were fluttering down
from the sky like when you drop a dollar
bill
just landing in gardens i know a cool
thing about
planes go on i can't wait to hear what
this is
okay this is i think a world war ii
story oh of course it is
not my favorite war but listen you've
got to have a backup so
um it's not my backup favorite or to be
honest with you i think that's the walls
of the roses
so anyway the point is that um
in i think world war ii um
they they noticed that a lot of planes
that all the planes that came back
um they were trying to basically they
wanted to figure out
where most planes were getting hit or
like um
where could a plane get hit and still
survive right
um because then if you know if you could
survive being hit in that area of the
plane they didn't want to spend extra
money in trying to figure out how to um
put more armoring on that area of the
plane
and they noticed um that planes just
didn't really get hit much in the engine
and they were like oh that's good to
know so we don't need to work on making
um the engines safer
until someone pointed out it's just that
the planes that get hit in the engine
don't come back in the archaeological
record
when you look at mali and zimbabwe
in the in the past they would trade
things i think it was the i'm going to
get mixed up which one traded with which
but the inland niger delta
was rich in gold so they traded it all
away
for salt yeah because that you need salt
to survive and if you've got all the
gold in the world doesn't matter if you
even got salt
so they were trading it but obviously
salt doesn't show up in the
archaeological record
so everyone just thought wow what a
generous nation giving away this gold
they're like no we're hungry for that
salt
sweet sweet salt yeah um yeah crazy
about the plane it is amazing how
little planes crash nowadays yeah right
i mean because that's really a new story
about you know a plane
going wrong but everyone still lives
yeah although in
holland on the same day another plane
had to land and take off because its
engine exploded and littered
places with a with metal as well that's
weird
yeah doesn't that seem like something at
the beginning of a sherlock holmes
episode
oh it does yeah um yeah it's a bit
sinister isn't it
we watched james bond the spy who loved
me last night and this starts off with
an american submarine and a russian
submarine both getting
disappeared and you don't know how
although we predicted it immediately
because we've seen
the one where the spaceship gets eaten
up by the biggest spaceship and we were
like oh they're definitely going to get
eaten up by a big boat
and that's what happens spy who love me
good film disco james bond soundtrack it
was great
done by marvin hamlisch who is a
composer who is one of only two people
to get an uh to get a pegot so an egot
is an emmy a grammy and oscar and a tony
so four huge awards and only i think 16
people have had those it's really hard
to get them he's one of only two to get
a peg
which is that and a pulitzer prize the
other person
richard rodgers or someone another
composer um yeah but that did that disco
soundtrack you get the james bond theme
done in disco
style carly simon singing nobody does it
better which is the first james bond
song to not have the title of the film
as its title but is the title is in the
song
and the reason that john barry the usual
james bond composer didn't do the music
was because when they asked him to do it
he said
i can't go back to the uk tax reasons
which is you know always great in it
what a good man
um so alice hello tell me
about tell me something what you can
educate i i know what you want me to
tell you about tonight
i'll tell you about this are you talking
about this earlier this week and i want
to share it with you all right
so i've been teaching john dunn lately
now i thought he's dead how are you
teaching him
why that is i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
i'm as disappointed with myself as she
is with me
so john dunn uh is a poet in the 17th
century
um sort of early early most of his poems
were published in 1633.
i mean in the time the spanish
inquisition is still going on it is
going on yes correct although it wasn't
really in full swing let's be honest by
the way spanish inquisition
the catholic church to this day claims
that
over the span of the 400 years of the
spanish inquisition
only 300 people were killed now i've
seen
that church have never lied about
anything there's no cover-up there why
would there be alice i just
i feel like i'm you know you know how i
feel about pope francis i expect him to
do better than this
anyway he needs to set this right he
needs to come out and say i'm sorry
everybody
we killed 15 million people during the i
don't know what accent that was i don't
know that's my proprietary i don't think
they killed 15 million people during the
inquisition somewhere between 15 million
people and
300 yeah so anyway um so john dunn john
dunn is writing uh he's a court poet
uh in a time period where basically to
be cool you had to be able to write
poetry
and he was a real player um
the other thing is so you have the
printing press already the printing
press shows up in
england at least in like the 1480s maybe
no sorry 1440s what am i like
i know one of my jokes that i wrote but
never worked was um
when they asked uh gutenberg to uh they
said hey goodbye can you describe
the world he invented the printing press
describe remove scribes from the world
because once you can print you do not
need scribes thank you
i'm here all week try the elk
um all right so moving on from that
moment of
deep and searing regret i felt for my
marriage um
so in the printing press has been around
for a while but in this time period it's
still sort of a bit
dodgy uh socially to get yourself
published via print
so what what john poets like john dunn
would have done is they would have
written down their poems show them to
their friends and then their friends
would have copied those poems out if
they liked them and then it kind of
spreads like that right like a virus
um and his poems were very popular um he
wrote mainly sex poems
uh that's maybe a little glib but a lot
of his most famous poems are sex poems
so his most famous poem is called the
flea
and basically he's lying in bed with
this woman and he's trying to convince
this woman to have sex with him
and she doesn't want to have sex with
him for lots of very good reasons like
disease
pregnancy not wanting to destroy her
family name etc
and he points out that a flea
has just bitten him and then bitten her
and he's like we've already had sex babe
look our liquids have already mingled
in this flea okay so how can you be so
petty is to not let me have sex with you
after we've already
basically done it he's what's known as a
metaphysical poet uh which i don't
i it's metaphysical is one of those
words where i i learn
the definition continually and forget it
instantly so i'm not gonna go into it
but basically his poems all
um they take a central conceit and then
just expand on that conceit more and
more so for instance in this poem it's
three stanzas long the first stanza is
look like um mark but this flea and mark
in this
how little that which thou deniest me is
it sucked me first and now sucks thee
and in this flea our two bloods mingled
be
right wow also massively lazy to be like
look i don't want to try and ryan mingle
i'm just going to put b at the end of it
it sucks now now it sucks me and so our
blood is mingled b
that's the equivalent of adding izzle to
the end of every word so all your lives
rhyme
i uh yeah okay fair so um by the way
um a thing about early printing
or um the way that they used to write
this and he would have been aware of
this and this is my favorite thing to
teach my
um impressionable young students is that
um s's in the past
um looked like f's they would
write this massive looping s and then
cut off the
the bottom half of the s so you just end
up with this top half of a big s
and a little stem and so it looks like
an f so the point
is that when you read the poem in or
if you had read the poem at the time
contemporary uh printing
it would have looked a whole lot like
the poem read
um it [ __ ] me first and now [ __ ] thee
and in this flea are two bloods mingled
bee
and of course john dunn is doing that on
purpose because he's skis
so um that's the first stanza right and
then the second stanza is him being like
wait hang on it's even
more than just this flea has essentially
already had sex with both of us and
we've had sex with each other
the flea represents our marriage like
we're already
married because we've had this like
sacred
sacred you know moment between us of of
mingling of blood with family
is this like you know we have molecules
of shakespeare in
us and so we have had sex with
shakespeare i think that's around the
same logic yes yeah
um there was a theory in this time
period that uh every time you lost sex
uh or lost bodily fluids you lost power
uh so why did they bleed people with
leeches though well because
the it's to do with the humors right the
full humors
i understand humor alice so you have
four humors i can't remember them as
black bile yellow bile red bile
something else um
and collar anyway and so the idea is
that uh
it's possible for your biles to be out
of um
sort of sync and therefore that's why
it's good to bleed you but um
sort of wanking for instance was very
uh bad for you so because a man wants
he's
come is useless well it's just that he's
lost some of his strength
yeah okay cool um and so just like um
there's
you know tribes i mean again tribes are
such a general term but there are
peoples of the world who in and we're
speaking in the anthropological present
which means we're talking as if it is
when this was still a thing obviously
you know like in anthropology you'll
talk about the azande a tribe of people
the azandi
drink the blood from their cows to
provide valuable nutrition well maybe
not anymore but we talk about the
anthropological present as if it's the
present now
and um there are peoples who believe
that if you take a photo of them
you're stealing their soul they lose
because you take a photo of them so i
think it's a
kind of a similar vibe to that and so
john don deals with that he says
thou knowest that this cannot be said a
sin nor shame nor loss of maidenhead
um maidenhead means virginity yeah so
and there's a place in britain called
maidenhead
yeah i know it's with that anyway so he
um
he's talking about the flea right and
he's being like look the flea sucked
your blood do you feel weaker do you
feel like you're not a virgin anymore
don't be ridiculous so why is it
different if you [ __ ] me i don't see the
difference
right and then the second stanza is him
being like we're married
okay we're already married because of
this flea and then in between the end of
the second stanza and the beginning of
the
third stanza she um kills the flea
and he begins stanza 3 by saying cruel
and sudden
hast thou since purpled thy nail in
blood of innocence
and then he accuses her of murder um
and suicide as well um
and then he says not the best way to get
someone to sleep with you is it i don't
know it's quite convenient murderous
suicide and then he says look and can
you just pointing out
babe that uh you're not any weaker
now that that flea is dead are you and
so you won't be any weaker
if you give your blood to me either
so let's have sex um so that's that's
his most famous poem but he writes i
mean
a lot of really beautiful poetry but
then later in his life
he had a religious conversion and his
religious conversion i find quite
amusing
because he writes poems to god which are
so similar to his sex poems to his
mistresses
um first off he writes them mainly in
sonnet form and sonnets are like
traditionally a romance
structure so already that's quite
disrespectful
um and my favorite of his religious
sonnets is called batter my heart
three-person
god and it yeah no it's quite hot and he
basically he starts off by being like
look i want you to destroy me god i want
you to just
[ __ ] me up and make me better he doesn't
say
but that's really the vibe and then um
and then he's
he he he um refuses entirely to take any
responsibility for him
not being a good christian he's like
look if i'm not a good christian it's
because
you made me not good enough for being a
christian
and then he says and it's very
interesting from a kind of like
genderqueer perspective he's like
i'm betrothed to satan and
i need you to rescue me from this
marriage to satan
and and god's reading it like who's
fatan
i've never heard of this guy fate and
fat anne he's engaged to a fat anne
um and to understand the next bit you
need to understand that in this time
period
there was uh a kind of belief
in religious orgasms so this is why i
asked alice to tell us about john doe
yeah chris got real excited about the
religious orgasms
how do you hear the phrase religious
orgasms and not get excited
so basically yeah there was this idea
that um
to some degree finding god would feel
like having the best orgasm of your life
um and there are statues like this i
think there's i think one of the most
famous ones is a statue i believe of
saint teresa
um where she's just coming
um you know because she's found god and
so as you can imagine if john dunn is
going to be a christian
that's the kind of christian he wants to
be so he start he ends the poem by being
like i will
never be chased unless you ravish me
um and that's all he wants he's just
like god like if you want me to be a
good christian
you gotta give me that sweet sweet
religious orgasm i'm waiting for it
how can i be a good christian without
that that way all
prayers end with oh man i find that
blasphemous and disrespectful
well you are just like a spanish monarch
so there you go john i don't know that
much about his life
even though it was quite interesting but
it's worth it for learning about
religious orgasms well i just like him
i i think he's i think i'd fall for it
if he was on tinder nowadays
very good um well that's the that's the
end thank you alex for telling us all
about that thank you for
thank you for undermining the concept of
the podcast throughout it as well we're
not getting yeah we're changing the
title it's not because she doesn't
read the news i think you're not being
vigorous enough i think if you were you
know making
the news you know more detailed and
boring i would i would not know as much
about it
to be fair that is true although i i am
aware this is to
entertain us and others first and
foremost but i will rename the podcast
so it will now be called deep and
searing regret for our marriage
i think that's going to be a real hit at
the end of the podcast you know what we
do we rap and by we i mean me alice has
the suggestions
um there's freestyle about the week's
news give me the first topic in three
two one a goal ted cruz leaving his dog
snowflake behind when he went to cancun
so cock-a-hoop when you're on holiday
but you forgot the pooch should be on
the steps staring out the glass in your
door all the press crown round they see
it with this poor like oh
i've been abandoned by ted wish i got
dog food which i've been fed
but no they're in cancun 300 but at
least
they remove my collar walking around the
house every piss that i take on the rug
my name is snowflake that's a giant but
the left the liberals
everybody in texas shiver you all how
did the dog survive if there's no
heating would have been moaning crying
bleating
defeating in the 2024 ted cruz you won't
be
president no more poor little doggies
ever have a fear i can go on holiday i
might visit north korea when i'm there
it's okay and nk kim jong-un
kept covid away even though it's kind of
near china
nobody got it there inside you all the
along so
crisp and clean looking like tasty
crispy creams cause i'm thinking donuts
from the spanish that we said
nobody in korea covered dead well in the
south inhaling in their mouth they'd be
going to the er what's this about why
are those in the north who are starving
not getting that covered charming but
still they hacked like the sony pictures
let's move on yeah the one mars rover
tweeting oh
yeah red planet with the perseverance
here little martian that's an
alien he's like oh a new robotic friend
coming down from the sky
this such fun pew pew destroy with a ray
gun like mars attacks
they shoot it so faster sending all the
pictures right back to nasta
oh nasta like nasty chris jenner got a
plan so crafty
making sure that kim and kanye can
separate so it's only
1k 1 000 ways that they divorce
why did they do it well partially of
course because kanye has a very troubled
life and kim won't put up with that
[ __ ] as a wife so many families in the
kardashians the beats almost done so
we're rushing it in
last one that we're gonna do last that
we fit alice wins not paying attention
when i spit
yeah spanish rapper he'd be putting in
prison he's like oh the french king
doesn't like chisholm i had to say
french not spain because i'd be
inside prison with him t he don't
blaspheme don't praise terrorist acts
otherwise
like pass all you're gonna get swacked
in
prison you just combined pablo and
hassell into one word i did it's
it's a portmanteau um yes uh
i find this so stressful by the way i
recognize you're doing all the work but
coming like yeah it's hard it's hard
work it's hard it is hard work
um well thank you for alice for doing
all the hard
heavy lifting though welcome darling um
anytime
yeah well that's the as the end thank
you to colonel whitachen for giving us a
cameo thank you to you
for listening as always please do leave
a little comment and
tell us you know oh hey uh not enough
elk for my liking
but uh we will we gratefully listen do
subscribe via spotify or apple podcast
leave a little rating or review
on the apple podcasts app share it with
a friend and if you want to find out
uh more about us and follow us on the
social media
then alice win is available at uh let
them eat books
um with underscores instead of spaces
and i am available at chris turner
commented they're both on instagram
instagram yes when we say available we
are actually married so you know we're
you can find us on there what a bad joke
to end the podcast
i really wish i'd saved the describe the
world
for the end yes that would have been
absolutely a banger wouldn't it really
love it anything you want to add alice
win
not at all thank you for listening from
me from her goodbye